thousands of people took part in protest
in multiple countries over the weekend
to oppose new restrictions on people who
do not get their vaccines demonstrations
in Paris turned violent as you see over
a law requiring people to show that
they've been vaccinated or tested
negative to enter restaurants planes and
other public spaces Australia Italy and
the UK also had protests Elizabeth
Palmer has more on this story
thousands of demonstrators came out on
Saturday in Paris to protest against
stricter anti-covered measures when the
scuffles turn violent the police use
tear gas to disperse the crowd but that
public anger didn't deter French
legislators
they passed a law last night that will
make vaccines mandatory for health
workers and vaccine passports essential
to get into museums Cinemas and
festivals
outside the Louvre Museum on the weekend
checks were already underway which took
Nelly Breton off guard
at first I was Furious she said but then
I calmed down and realized there were
medical reasons to be rigorous
over at the Eiffel Tower the system was
working smoothly everyone's showing
either an electronic proof of
vaccination or a hard copy and for those
who didn't have either one there was
rapid on-site testing so anyone who had
a ticket could enjoy the views from this
famous landmark newly reopened after
nine months all across Europe there have
been demonstrations in Athens where the
Greek government has said health workers
have no choice but to get fully
vaccinated and in Italy where a peaceful
crowd marched against the vaccine
passports they'll soon need for places
like gyms and museums and for indoor
dining
as tourism comes to life again in Europe
people may not love the new rules but
they do believe they're better than
another lockdown and evidence from
France shows that they are definitely
boosting vaccinations Among The
Reluctant
I didn't want to admitted Ruben Ben
Amron but there are now just too many
restrictions
like Reuben may be more interested in
getting a vaccine passport than getting
the vaccine itself but to Public Health
officials that counts as a win
now here in Britain there are no vaccine
passports yet but prime minister Boris
Johnson has warned they're coming in
September for among other crowded places
nightclubs and already the nightclub
owners are not happy they're pushing
back they say we've been hammered by
this pandemic this is just going to make
everything worse Anthony Elizabeth
Palmer in London thank you Liz